but here's a little challenge
if you start something and you have to
taste yourself
okay this is what happened you have to
rough those nails and that hand gesture
the biggest turn off yo if i see a
girl's nails and they longer than this
what you mean
guys and ladies ladies maybe they do it
for themselves
okay so ladies if you do for yourself
live your best life not gonna say
nothing
but fellas am i crazy when you see them
long-ass nails looking like
saber-toothed tigers right
do you get turned on or does that be
like uh
i'm not saying you'd be like man i can't
i can't touch it like i don't know
what's gonna do that but doesn't it turn
you off a little bit am i crazy
let me know in the comments below i love
it when they type on the phone yes
they can't go like this
i said oh my god
you know what i do respect though
literally every girl like that that i
slept with
when they put their hands on my my pinor
they've never messed it up like they're
so used to having these
they respect it but that's why they beat
this
yeah they do the whole zara pose yeah i
mean like no
let's look like this man
hey to eat the elm if it's your thing
that's your thing i mean
women do it for themselves we got all
these things we want in a man a list of
things he got to be tall you got to be
dark he got to be handsome you got to
have pretty see
he got to be a family man he got to be
financially safe we got to be rich you
got to be successful he got to be
all these things and we ain't even have
the things on that list
he got to be a family man she might talk
to your mama in six months but you want
him to be a family man
so this is what i challenge you to do
can i ask you something
can you come with those nails and not
come with the
no it's a package deal right yeah it's
like a three-piece combo but you got to
show them you got to show your nail when
you get your nails then you got to show
them
how okay
you don't think that you're
it's kind of like when a guy works out
and you're like hey man where's the
drawer story
it's over there bro it's over there it's
over there bro
it's over i think it's really over there
bro
you gotta need to go you need to go and
fly them stairs up and after that you
slow down
how you doing brother put it there yeah
put it there alba
you're afraid no
[Music]
you want him to be understanding you're
the least understanding person in your
circle of friends but he got to be
understanding fix you fix you
okay so i guess she's basically saying
if you are
got a lot of negative attributes don't
be expecting the best you got to match
it up
very basic advice you know what i mean
but before we move on to derek jackson
she got a whole lot of flack because of
that women we
were not happy and i believe she was
talking to women but i believe her
advice
goes both ways but just like us sure
whenever we talk about
issues that men deal with and we don't
talk about the opposite that's our
experience right
so her experience with her girlfriends
and stuff like that is that i
understand what she was saying you match
it up what she said was
it was breaking down the saying what do
you bring to the table
yeah if you ask all these things about a
man and you complain that you're single
but you have to understand what you
bring to the table and that goes both
ways
so quite a few of y'all tagged me in
this video asking what my thoughts were
if i agree and let me just say real
quick yes i do agree with her overall
premise overall what i got from what she
was saying was that men or women but
especially
women here specifically women if you
want a man of a certain caliber of a
certain level then you need to be on
that level something comparable
or bring something to the table that
compliments what he brings to the table
you know if you want a boston
or somebody who has the bag to be able
to flip that back be able to grow that
back manage that money et cetera i don't
know why people say this list most men
who are making money are not trying to
find you
and then have you flip their money for
them or do all those other stuff most
men don't care about that
no i understand that not in the sense
that yo you got to flip my money or
whatever you got to be in my business
oh if it's not in my business at all but
you can't be a liability yeah but that's
there's a huge difference
guys don't come in hundreds of thousands
i know there's a difference you
shouldn't be looking for a man in which
you would be a downgrade for him
you would be a step back from him that's
just what it is now
what i found interesting was a lot of
the feedback was from women who were
agreeing
and that seemed to come as a shock to a
lot of guys and i saw dudes commenting
stuff like oh y'all don't want to hear
this troop when it comes from us because
we be saying it all the time
we've been saying it because it's coming
from a woman now y'all want to hear it
and i'ma just speak from observation
that i don't think that's quite the case
i don't think women have
as much of a problem with the truth as
people say i think a lot of women have a
problem whenever the truth is being
misused as a weapon or a device of
degrading them or cutting them down
or attacking their self-esteem or that
women have a problem
whenever the whole this this truth right
here is being misapplied to
the exact opposite of what this girl is
talking about now the truth is
women got an issue because the way men
say it is super dry does it
yeah it's basically the tone yeah and i
understand it it's like if it's a tender
spot for you
well someone who's just gonna jab a
needle into it and be like here's your
dose
this might not feel great you might not
want to see that person oh good day
siraba we're going to give you
we're going to give you your uh we're
going to give you a vaccine are you
ready
three two one
i get it but anyways i think that's the
big thing it's like sometimes
you can agree with someone's advice but
also the way that they say it just
doesn't sit right with you
and that's the reason why a lot of women
don't like us
me specifically oh they don't like well
yeah they don't like you because you're
dry they don't like me because they
go out with a white letter
i was thinking
i was thinking about i'm like i'm not
gonna break this [ __ ] up i'm gonna tell
you real quick i was yo
yo no you don't you want to know what
happened the other day yo
you wanna i wasn't gonna
i was just i didn't get it i was yo i
was on that there's this app called
clubhouse
all right oh yeah because what she's
talking about is a woman who is
unemployed busted disgusted ain't got no
money but she wants six or seven figure
man
you know she want to build gates or one
or you know
she's talking to a woman that has no
family values
don't care about nobody in her family
etc but she want a man who is a family
man who's family oriented
that makes total sense but too often i
see this exact same
truth being shot at women who are bosses
who are entrepreneurs who make plenty
money who are doing they think who work
hard
have ambition and whenever that woman
says i want a man who's equally yoked i
want a man who makes six figures
just like me they're told that that
money that they got
all that they worked hard for don't mean
nothing in fact i saw a video literally
of this situation where a woman who was
making six figures in her business
was like as soon as she said i want a
man who's on my level in this area
the attention was turned to what her
face was on a one-to-ten
what her dress size was um you know she
was a a
mother or except like come on yeah
no that's what i said earlier a lot of
men don't care how much money you make
i said that in the the the video he's
referencing the kevin samuels once and i
say it again
a lot of dudes don't care a lot of dudes
don't want you making that
they don't care so when you say i want a
dude who's my equal i was like
what you're judging him on what he's
judging you want to completely different
things
so when you i make six figures nobody
cares when you see a group of girls and
say oh girl so you you have a new man
yeah what does he do for a living he's a
doctor
[Music]
when man do what does she do she's a
doctor god damn she's smart
did she she did that we don't care like
oh money
it's it's the different things we
different things we value oh yeah it's a
different thing like yo listen sometimes
i meet girls on these platforms you know
i mean big big names big big social
media followings
doesn't make them any more attractive to
me at all which is
why like you know when people were like
you can't god need someone on your level
it's like that's not what happened for
me
i'm gonna be honest with you it's not
endearing at all in fact it's normally a
turn off
like if someone's got a huge following
and they're doing i'm not interested
it's not because i want power over them
for me it's just like i know what comes
with this job and all that other
[ __ ]
why would i want that in my partner i
already got it i'll deal with it myself
i don't want my partner who's dealing
with a sentence and we
that's what we talk about whenever we
have conversation the same
you want to believe what this i'm like i
don't care what he said or the woman
that says you know what
i'm not only family oriented but
i'm doing the work of both me as a mom
and what should be the father in my
child's life
i've seen that woman get this truth of a
message and not only is that like
disregarded
what's really weighted is the fact that
she made a mutual decision with another
man to even become a parent
that's what counts that's where the
attention goes one can
look at it both ways one can look at it
and be like it's honorable
that you decide to take care of a child
that the man decided to run off on
and also say you're not a desirable
partner for most people those two things
can be true
i don't know a single single mom who
would say her having a child makes her
dating prospects easier
or better nor would i see a dude to be
like damn i love the fact
like some people accept it and they'll
be like i'll still be able to work past
it and that's great but a lot of people
don't want anything and that's not just
men that's also women right i know women
who don't want a dated dude who's got
kids because of
baby mama drama or whatever stuff like
that right derek confuses me because he
makes sense off the top and then he
starts to say this stuff and i'm like
bro have you thought this through at
all it's not a mystery to your fans or
to men
that single moms have these dating
issues or not well sought after so i'm
just like
what are you doing man you know i have a
problem where i want to see
i want to believe that people are not
trying to be disingenuous and sometimes
people make it really hard
yeah because because sometimes they come
down they're like the sky is orange and
i'm like [ __ ]
look up sometimes like you want to give
the benefit of the doubt but the doubt
is right there looking at you it's like
a
it's an insult to their intelligence
whenever you know this conversation
comes up and a woman says i want this
caliber of man in terms of his character
in terms of his family values and it
seems like the way that they're measured
isn't on the same scale
they want a man they're looking for this
character and et cetera et cetera but
then whenever it comes to measuring a
woman
and how that woman is seen as desirable
or attractive it's all about
their sexual value it's all about how
they can stroke a man's ego they want a
man again for this character and stuff
but whenever the conversation comes to a
woman it is
again what's your weight what's your age
how many kids you got
how what's your body count derek are you
surprised that men value women for
different reasons that women value men
of course
we expect different things from each
other women don't expect for men
what men expect from women women don't
want a relationship and be like
hey man i want you to leave but i'm also
lead i want you to protect
me but i'm also going to no that's not
how it works we got roles
as a result of those roles that most
people like to subscribe to
there are different expectations for
what you're going to look for in your
part yeah i don't care if you make money
big whoop-dee-doop surprise surprise
don't care what you got in your bank
account so long as it's not
deeply in the negative don't care but
you know what i will care about
are you able to manage your household
that's gonna be very endearing to me
or you can keep your place clean you can
make food for yourself you enjoy
taking care of folks that's going to be
interesting to me not because
i want someone to cook for me every day
i like cooking i like making i like
taking care of stuff
but that's qualities that i do look for
in a partner that is going to be 10
times more important
than how much money you make and that's
facts and i don't think you're the only
one
i feel like i'm basically saying abcdefg
[ __ ] we know your viewers know why are
we lying
but anyways i think they're saying you
know what this is the truth of how
men these days evaluate me or find value
on in me or you know gauge their
interest in me
then why can't we address the issue with
that because there is an issue with that
no there's not an issue ladies you guys
made the choice you want to go on to the
job market
you want to do all this other stuff you
want the social liberation you said if i
could have a kid and i have it on my own
i'm gonna do it on my own whatever cool
i ain't mad at you yo be be a
billionaire be a millionaire i don't
care
but don't be mad because we don't
respect you for the personal decisions
that you made
you do it for you but now you're mad
because we don't value that in you
we never said we were going to nor do we
care
yo so you need to stop making that idea
of like i need to be this boss
independent fine but also understand
men just don't give and that's your
choice and that's not a problem society
you can't get mad at us for why we value
you the same way we can get mad at you
for why you value us
i want a man to protect me why i don't
why don't you protect yourself
go take an mma class why don't you go
handle that why why wha what
but it is what it is that's how women
work i don't know why
women like i spend all this time being
so powerful i bought
all those magic cards and women don't
value me for that you understand they do
not engage i'm like yo but i got all
these cards
all these magic cards i have all
the dragon ball that i can have
and nobody's gonna get on my dragon ball
cause they don't value dragon balls
y'all know
i don't need to i don't need to school
you guys i like i feel like i'm just
gonna be redundant so
basically i'm gonna just leave it to
y'all maybe i'm wrong if i am leaving
the comments of what we'll hear up
good lord man derek you started off good
garth olympia strikes again the force
strikes back bar notes empire the empire
strikes back
the empire says